let's try luke from indiana luke from
indiana please save
us
luke i can hear you sort of what's going
on me
yeah oh how's it going it's going well
so basically what i wanted to talk about
is a lot of people that don't
live in rural areas don't understand
truly how deep the uh
urban rural divide is like yeah with the
vaccinations we've been hanging at about
40 in indiana for weeks now right
and it's just not going up yeah you know
i um i actually went to indiana
a couple of years ago and i was in rural
northern indiana so it was like uh
goshen and um oh really i'm about uh
i'm about an hour west that i'm in
valparaiso okay yeah it was like goshen
and shipshawana
and all these little little places and
spending some time there
i under it's like of course all those
people voted for trump you drive around
all you see is uh amish folks
shooting ranges and evangelical churches
if that's what you grow up around and
you you're not
exposed to different types of people
you're not exposed to
hey there's a whole alternative view
here of empiricism and science
of course abortion and guns are the most
important issues and of course you voted
for donald trump even if half the stuff
he says isn't even
um is isn't isn't is not even uh true
and sincere so yeah i think that
a lot of people who just spend their
time in cities they don't
get how it gets to this point in the
rural parts of the country and i think
it would be useful for people to spend
some time there and better understand
how it happens as you're pointing out
oh yeah and i think a lot of the problem
too is a lot of the people here
like you said they grew up in that
scenario yeah and they don't feel like
anyone's trying to reach out and change
their mind at all like
right i live in one of the more outside
of indianapolis it's one of the more
liberal places in indiana because we
have a steel mill about
40 minutes away that's one of the
biggest
employers in the area right but even
that a lot of those people voted for
trump just because they don't think that
any of the democrats are doing anything
to
reach out to them they feel pretty
alienated right
and a lot of them care about economics
more than anything but
yeah no one's reaching out to you you
can't expect them to change i don't
think
yep i think as a great starting point it
would be great for people that are more
urban on the left
to spend some time in these areas to
just start understanding what's going on
i
appreciate you bringing that point up of
course
all right luke from indiana thank you
very much an almost
unblemished set of phone calls today
with just one dropped call and otherwise
almost perfect audio
people getting to questions beautiful
beautiful thing
i'm sorry i wasn't able to speak to
everybody who's holding i see about 30
other people holding
we will take calls again and i hope to
speak to you the next time